In this section, we'll cover adding the logic to our Blueprint to listen for our Pause Dispatcher event,
pause the playing sequence, and wait for player input.
So we'll jump back over to the project, and in our BP Sequence Trigger Brox example,
this is where we're going to start adding the additional logic to this Blueprint.
I'm going to take our Event Begin Play and just move it up a little bit out of the way.
And the first thing that I want to do is drag off of the Event Begin Play,
and I'm going to search for Get Actor of Class.
Go ahead and do this.
And then under the Actor Class, this is where we're going to drop down,
and we're going to search for our BP Sequence Manager.
Select this, hit Compile.
Next, we're going to drag off of this Get Actor's Class,
and we're going to add a Bind Event.
And we can go ahead and turn back on Context Sensitive if need be.
And we're going to look for, and it'll probably be at the very top here,
we're going to look for a Bind Event to the Pause Dispatcher.
Now, if you're having trouble finding it, we can just continue typing here.
So Bind Event to, and we're going to do Pause to the Pause,
Bind Event to, and uncheck Context Sensitive, and there we go.
Bind Event to Pause Dispatcher.
And there we go.
And I'm going to select all these nodes and just move them up a little bit more
so we have some room.
And now what I'm going to do is drag off of our event,
and we'll just keep Context Sensitive on,
and we're going to look for a Add Event, Add Custom Event.
And we'll give this a name just called Pause Dispatcher.
There we go. There's our custom event.
Go ahead and hit Compile, and we are ready to go.
Now, if you do get this target on the Bind Event to Pause Dispatcher
is not selected, what we need to do is just drag our Out Actors to the target itself,
hit Compile, and our error should go away.
Now, from our Pause Dispatcher event, I'm going to drag off of this
and create a Branch Node.
This is going to allow us to be able to target a condition,
and if that condition is true, do something.
If it's false, do something else.
Now, in this case, our condition is going to be our IsPlane variable
that we created earlier.
So I'm just going to drag this IsPlane and drag it onto the condition.
You see that it's automatically hooked up.
Go ahead and hit Compile, and we should be good to go.
So the next thing that we're going to do is drag our Main Sequence variable into here,
and we are going to select our Get Main Sequence.
And then from here, if we drag off, we are going to search for a Pause.
Now, we can keep Context Sensitive here,
and we are looking for the Sequence Player, Pause Sequence Player.
And you can see the engine automatically creates our translator.
We'll move this up to here.
So next, we're going to connect from our branch, the True, to our Pause.
And essentially, what this is going to do, move back here,
is when our event is fired, we're going to create this custom event,
and if it's playing, we're going to go ahead and Pause.
So again, the event fires. It is playing for the check.
Yes, it is.
Let's go ahead and Pause our Sequence Player.
The last thing that we want to do is drag off of our Pause,
and we are going to search for a Destroy Actor.
And you'll notice that the target is Self.
So it's going to be this Blueprint,
in particularly the instance that's going to be added to our level.
So this hails from what we created in our 205 class,
which was we want to go ahead and destroy the Actor,
which in this case will be the collision volume,
the Blueprint itself in the level.
Not all of them, just the single instance,
to ensure that the player won't retrigger this Sequence again.
So this is an optional thing, but we'll do that just as a check.
So this should be the logic that we need for our Pause event.